Ryan Dorsey speaks out about wife Naya  Rivera 'z arrests the 34 year old took  to Twitter on Tuesday writing this isn't  some reality show this is our life and I  asked that everyone especially the media  please respect our privacy and treat us  the situation how you would want a loved  one to be treated Rivera was arrested  and charged with domestic battery  against Dorsey on Saturday night in West  Virginia a spokesperson for the Kanawha  County Sheriff's Office tells ET that  Dorsey claimed Rivera had struck him in  the head and phased adding that the two  were allegedly arguing over their  two-year-old son Josie Dorsey showed a  video to police me during the alleged  incident as for Rivera she was taken to  the County Magistrate Court where she  was arraigned and later released on bail  now the Glee star's arrest comes just a  month after she filed to dismiss her  divorce from Dorsey she filed for  divorce last November after two years of  marriage  [Music]